i'm adam allardy i work here at ebay i'm
an applied researcher
why do i choose ebay it's a pretty cool
company they sell the craziest stuff
you'll ever believe
there's like denim jean jackets with
nick cage on the back
and this kind of stuff is all over the
place so it's definitely cool
the new york office is brand new
probably less
it's less than a year and what does the
new york office do
well we own the home page of ebay so the
brand new feed
is developed right over there you might
even see one of the guys
he's hiding okay and also all the
merchandising for ebay
is also going to be run out of the new
york office so that's billions of
dollars worth of ebay business
run right out of here so it's a major
investment ebay has made
in new york which is really cool so
why you're here is to find out how we
use scala and hadoop
and given all the data we have the two
pair very nicely together as you will
see all right
so let's get started okay
these are some things we'll cover um
polymorphic function values you know
higher kind of types
scholeski star operator some use of
macros
um so okay
i i'm kidding like i have no clue what
those things are
um so that was a test all right
uh we're not gonna be talking about that
we're gonna be talking about practical
uses of scala
i don't know if any of those could
increase revenue on ebay but if they
could
let me know after the talk i'll be happy
to hear about it
okay so what we're actually going to
talk about
why scala why hadoop why we chose scala
and hadoop
and i'm going to go through a lot of
code so
bear with me but i assume everyone is
familiar with scala so it shouldn't be
too much of a shock
all right cool okay
all right so why scala so these are like
the typical
reasons why you'd use it but the jvm's
really important because at a big
company like ebay
they've made huge investments in jvm
technology so they know
how to scale it you know they know how
to monitor it they have all these
systems
up and running that do this for you for
free
so that's kind of a huge selling point
for sure
um it's functional functional so scala
is really cool
when i first saw options and ethers i
was blown away
you just can't get that kind of you just
can't get that in java
and scholar gives you that kind of
conciseness
it also is extremely expressive so you
say what you want to do
and maybe it doesn't make a lot of sense
to non-scholar users when i first saw
scala i thought it was like a total mess
and like i thought as i wrote things
more in a scala way
it became less readable but i realized
it was more expressive
over time so i think that's where you
end up getting as you
scala which is really cool uh how to
convince your boss
you should probably just work somewhere
where your boss already agrees with you
so that's my advice there
um yeah
so another thing that's good about scala
is a lot of people
like there's tons of haskell tutorials
on the web i feel like haskell
is maybe not going to break into the
enterprise but scala has a chance
so by blending the functional style and
object or into programming
scala might bring people closer to that
you know pure functional
programming that like haskell haskell
offers without like beating you over the
head with it
so that's definitely cool and all my
life
i've always wanted a type save build
system and scala finally delivered it
all right okay yeah that's
this happens a lot okay but i found it
so this is a weird i found it easier to
write the bullet points on this slide
than the last slide which is odd
but um there are certainly some
complaints
the compile times can be very long if
you have a large application
ask anyone who works at foursquare and
they will tell you all about it
break backwards compatibility so every
time they release a new version
you know they'll they'll break something
they're known for doing this the
java util list is the same as it was in
like 94
that's not the case with scala
complicated again i think that's kind of
just people get used to the functional
style
i think over time everyone's going to
kind of like
get to understand it and they'll realize
what they're seeing is not really
complicated they just didn't
quite know how to wrap their heads
around it at first
this is one point that i found
personally it leads to madness and i
think scala
kind of goads you in a certain way and
let me try to explain that
with some code all right so
you're looking at a trait which is
a type class that kind of tells you you
can create an
object with certain parameters and it
will only be created once
and if you ever try to change the
parameters it just won't work
right so like you can see here this is
some crazy skull stuff i needed to
make this uh covariant to like get the
implicits to
to work um i had to make p
um a tuple to get like random parameters
into this uh code i use lazy valves here
to kind of capture the fact that the
thing is created once
and then here's a cool use of either so
like if it blows up
you get a throwable back but it won't
actually keep trying so like
the main use of this was i o on hadoop
so if someone accidentally
tried to do i o in a in the context of a
mapper
this would prevent you from like
crashing the node uh the name node so
this is very useful
if you've ever crashed name node um
so and then down here there's some code
like how you actually get it
and it sets these parameters and then
returns a lazy thing
okay cool uh does that make sense
everybody
all right uh so then here's just how you
use it
um this is you know just how you call it
you call it with that
and then you know type inference figures
out what you were asking for
based on the parameters you passed in i
didn't show it in
the actual implementation of the
implicit here
but it's around okay so here's my point
though
all right so this is used by one client
class in my entire application
so show some self-restraint scala like
goads you
to make these really cool frameworks
it's like super expressive you read all
these blog posts about advanced features
and just you just want to use them but
you got to watch out so this is one of
the things i got to say is really
practical in scholarly
you want to just get the job done you
don't need to do it the coolest possible
way
you can and i learned that firsthand
all right cool so that's sums up
kind of like why we chose scala um
and it also blends into making it easier
to use mapreduce since mapreduce is on
on java as you all know so for those of
you that don't know
what hadoop is this is kind of like a
high-level view
so these are files so these are just
files
they could be in various formats this is
like an abstract class
and then they get sucked into mappers
and you can think of a mapper as
like a map function in scala you just
like map over a list of things
uh and then it spits out data here
it gets sorted and then it gets merged
so
then it gets fetched by these reducers
and it's merged and sorted again
and a reducer is like an aggregator so
um
it's not exactly analogous to reduced
function
but it's close enough so you get
um keys and you get an iterator over
those keys
and my next slide will kind of make that
a little more clear
so so this is like a full mapreduce task
like you could do no reduce if you want
you could do no map if you want
but this is generally what like a full
unit of mapreduce work
looks like so it's pretty tricky like
and to actually implement it um
yeah it's actually implemented you need
to
implement these interfaces in java so
like i said before
here's the map interface you see a key
and you see a value
and then you output another key and a
different value
so that's basically what a mapper does
and then the reducer you notice key 2
from here came in as key 2 down here
and then you get an iterator of all the
values
of this that you outputted from before
so this is pretty simple
um you know it is very low level though
and it's nice to put abstractions on top
of this to actually get any real work
done
imagine trying to do a join in this it's
probably difficult for people even who
know how to do it to do it in raw
mapreduce because it's just not it's
just not natural
um so that's kind of the problem there
as far as like
you guys choosing to use mapreduce or
not i think
this is kind of my prediction but a lot
of these algorithms
um that are coming out are like tuned
for mapreduce and i think you're going
to see more and more of that
so while you could probably do things on
a single machine
at a smaller company you're probably
going to start to see like
a lot of mind share around mapreduce so
even when you have like these
medium-sized data sets
it still might be easier to use it just
because of all the code out there
that's available for you all right so
how about ebay and mapreduce and hadoop
okay so we have petabytes of data we
have
thousand node hadoop cluster which is
pretty big
and i mentioned before the multi-billion
dollar merchandising business
that this hadoop cluster supports it
also supports search
which is used quite heavily on ebay and
there's lots of users and items
can't exactly say how many all right so
how do i use mapreduce so this is a good
question if you just googled mapreduce
and like framework
you'd get back a ton of stuff and
you'd probably be lost so i remember the
first time i saw the mapreduce website
it had
pig hive like hdfs
core mapreduce that is this is
overwhelming right
so what do you do um so
the whoops uh the worst thing to do
is probably write raw mapreduce
you'll spend a lot of your time in
boilerplate and it just won't be fun
you're not going to enjoy yourself so
what did people early on
say oh well we'll just make an
abstraction over mapreduce
and they came up with pig which is kind
of like
it's a scripting language but it lets
you integrate java code and other code
with it
um then they came up with hive without a
facebook and that was basically sql
queries
so if you if you just need to know the
average of a column like
use hive don't don't go crazy um but
there is a lot of setup
to get hive going also so this is where
the picture starts to get a little bit
better
um we land on cascading
cascading is a java framework it's built
over mapreduce it kind of abstracts
the whole mapping sorting producing
bit and it lets you write kind of
natural code
and you're going to see some examples of
this this is also
this this is also maybe not the
the least amount of code you'll ever
have to write in your life but it's very
maintainable
and i'll talk more about that as well
some other options maybe scooby
uh you guys are scala people you
probably heard about this
it's basically a mapreduce framework
written in scala
and remember when i talked about madness
before i think a lot of the things in
there were like to scratch
some itches like you have to compile it
with the y dependent types flag
you know you're like in in different
territory
so those guys um i think they're doing
great work
um but they're definitely still working
on it
uh and here we come to the the punch
line here it's kind of like
scalding is kind of the way
we've evolved here so we have to to be
fair to history
we have a lot of pig code we have a lot
of cascading code
and now we're creating a lot of scalding
code
okay so how do you make a decision all
right here's a kind of long quote
i'll give you a moment to digest it
all right so the basic idea is
some guy built his house on sand and
then flood came
you know floods come a lot when you're
in software engineering
and it got washed away except for the
guy who built his house on you know
it's like stone it's not gonna get
washed away okay so
i believe all right that scalding
combines the best of pig and cascading
and you're going to see this in a moment
with some examples
um and
you might say during this like why we
didn't go with scooby
because it's raw scala and i think part
of the reason is
scalding is based off cascading which is
like an extremely strong base
so the abstractions they built there
have been like tuned over
years and there's a company backing it
so everything about it is like really
solid i think i ran into maybe one major
bug and it was fixed in the next version
so i trust the cascading people
big people too i do i do trust them as
well some of the scooby stuff was a
little immature
and it is getting a lot better but it's
not
perfect as as of yet uh maybe one day it
will be better and
i'll bring up some examples to contrast
it later on
okay so here's some good pig
all right so remember that mapreduce api
i showed you before
you don't have to write any code that
does that this is some
good big code you say hey load me this
file
give me some field names do some filters
this sounds a lot like
scala right here and then you can output
it
and then over here you could do some
other stuff you know get
some other fields and then store it
somewhere else another thing pig
is like doing joins and group buys so
joining
in that other api is like clearly
unintuitive
and you have to do some major hackery to
get it to work
so in pig you could just say hey join
these two
like variables by like some value
and it just magically works so i i
understand why everyone kind of like
flocked to this early on
so here's some bad pig all right so this
is the downside
let's see here so what's someone doing
here look it looks like they're taking a
pearl script
and sending to every node on the cluster
so
this this may not be a good idea i mean
do you even know where that pearl script
is stored i mean it could be in
someone's home directory
it's definitely in this scripts variable
but i don't know that looks a little
shady
all right so actually i don't actually
know what this code's doing because it
just says
envy terms stream some data through it
and i get it back out
so you know without a comment here i
really have no clue
what this perl script actually does so
this is
not so good another thing is
you can add java code to it so
right here you'll notice some java code
being called
again i really don't know what this java
code does
i'd have to actually look at the source
i'd have to find the jar
and that jar is as well like
probably imported via some script like
tag like this and then it's exported to
everything
on the cluster
okay so another problem with this so you
don't know where your source is
and you you wrote a bunch of scripts
that look like this
and now you decide right well script a
now depends on script b and then after
that's all done i have script c to run
so how are you going to string these
things together um
well that's kind of a problem because if
you don't always want to run a b and c
in that order maybe a is cached and it
gets updated every so often
you're going to need to actually like
string them together
using bash scripts or something like
that so you'll be like
there's no way people do that so that is
true there are
extra frameworks built like linkedin has
azkaban
which basically allows you to construct
a dag of all your dependencies
and lets you kick off that job so this
is just another layer of complexity that
you need to
like handle if you're going to write pig
code so
so that's kind of that um i just
mentioned about this
scheduling dag creation um
you know you need to use some external
framework or roll your own and it might
be tempting to just roll your own
because it's quicker and easier
but you end up then with all these
dependency problems and nobody knows
what's going on
i could say this from some experience
all right
okay so cascading rocks all right
i'll remind you again what it is it's
job framework
um it writes it basically treats
mapreduce as a stream of tuples
so you have tuples in scala imagine that
a stream of them
is just flowing through various
pipelines and that's
what cascading is at at a very high
level
um look it kind of addresses two of the
big problems i have with pig also
so it supports really large workflows so
i can
use all the abstractions available
available to me in java
which are plentiful and i could write
code with all of those
some really cool things are the the
automatic dag
generation so based on how you structure
your code in the cascading framework it
will compute
all the dependencies for you and it will
like actually output
a graph of everything that is there
which is super cool
um if if you just show somebody that
they'll
they'll be sold also parallel executions
if since it computed the graph of
everything it needs to do
then it could basically choose to do
things in parallel
and pig can't exactly do that out of the
box you'd need azkaban to do that
or some additional framework okay
um so also one other thing is because of
dag generation you can kind of cache
files
so if there's like a really heavyweight
job that needs to run you could cache it
on the disk and then you don't need to
run it every time you kick off
dependent jobs and i'll show you an
example of that later on also
okay so here's some code um
so basically here i'm saying hey create
a new master pipe
i give it a i give it a nice name and
then
you know i i'm gonna say filter some url
encoded strings out of this
and here's a field name i'm passing to
it um
now what is actually in this pipe are a
bunch of tuples
and they're all named so here's a name
of one of them
so there's a lot of good things about
this is like this is pretty clear
it's java code if i hold down control
and click in eclipse this will take me
to the source
and that's a beautiful thing especially
when you're coming from pig
where i couldn't exactly do that um and
then down here it's doing another thing
i'm saying like
filter more inappropriate queries and
you'll notice it's kind of like building
a pipeline
so like this variable is passed into
this thing
and then it's reassigned i just realized
it couldn't be reassigned because i made
that a vowel
um anyhow and then you'll see down here
that it's taken again and then you're
gonna group by
so you could say hey i know i have these
fields
grouped by them and then give me that
iterator it's that same iterator you saw
back in the the raw mapreduce api
so it could also do things like
secondary sort that's that's what's
going on here
uh does all this make sense cool
all right oh man what did someone do
here
okay so this is this is the output of
one of those dag calculations
now you may argue that possibly this
wasn't the best use of mapreduce
but the fact is it was very easy to do
in cascading and because of all the
the abstractions it gave me it was very
easy to do a loop
and cause all these things to happen and
then they get floated
there and there and there and it's
finally outputted um
this is this is really cool um
and it'd be very difficult to manually
put this into azkaban
i could imagine again you'd probably
argue i shouldn't do that
but this is this is definitely cool
all right so cascading issues hmm
all right so i can't really think of too
many um this is old ibm joke here
anyways um the point is
the only thing i could really think of
that's not good is
you have to still write a lot of code
because it's in java
people kind of complain about the
verbosity of java and
also you have a lot of pipelines it's
not always super clear
so i guess you could level that
complaint against it
um but again it's it's definitely
a good workhorse if you were to like
reach into the bag of hadoop tools and
pull out cascading
i don't think anyone would fault you
okay cool so now it's time for scalding
all right so welcome back to the world
of scala
and this is this is where scalding
really makes things cool so scalding
is a domain specific language written
on top of cascading it's done by twitter
they've done excellent work here um
okay so let's let's look at this code
for a little bit here
so it takes some arguments it extends a
job
uh that's like in scalding and then
here you're saying okay get me a text
input and that's the file name you know
in the args
and then now you're doing something
that's pretty skull like here
um so before i go into that this is this
is counting words so
you may have seen this example countless
number of times
so like hadoop is the best framework for
counting words ever built
and you'll see it implemented over and
over and over
so it's it's a very good example and it
really kind of illustrates the power
of each abstraction that every given
framework adds
so what do you got here you got some
flat maps going on
um it takes a string so i assume this
input was like line number and then some
text
and then i use this tokenize function to
spit out
an array of strings and you know what
flatmap
is going to do here it's going to like
create more and more
tuples that come out of this so then
you're like oh okay i have all these
words now
and i just want to get their size so i
group by them and do a size
and then i write it out uh i think
what's important to note here
is that you're writing code that's kind
of close to what you would actually do
if you were doing it on in memory so
that's really what the goal is here
um they don't want you writing like
streams and pipes and all these kind of
things
it's not really a natural scala
construct they want you to be reminded
what it is to write like scala code and
then you could be more productive
and so you start seeing things like flat
map you know what to do
as opposed to like some tuple named
every
you'd be a little bit more confused
so to be fair to scooby it has a very
similar interface
but again since scalding is built on top
of cascading
you're basically just proxying down to
cascading functions
which are really well designed and work
excellently
okay all right so okay so we chose to
use scalding so there's
still some problems we have to use it at
ebay um
we have these gigantic tables on hdfs
that have
you know a hundred or more fields in it
and
if i want just one of them i'm extremely
confused about how to get it often
um so if you just had to know the index
of it and someone changed it all your
code would be
kind of screwed so that wouldn't be good
so what could you use scalding for you
could definitely reduce the boilerplate
of actually finding fields in hdfs
tables if you want to call them tables
uh
it's super extensible so you'll see an
example of how we
extended scalding to do a lot of natural
things
that make our code a lot more readable
and definitely more extensible
uh so this is this is a good point um
new hires
so uh there was a big argument about
whether or not
people who get hired into doing this
kind of work
should start off directly with one of
these frameworks that's super high level
to get them productive right away so
that's kind of like why we're
pushing towards scooby and scalding it's
a lot less intimidating
than going right to raw mapreduce or
going right to cascading
the the problem is when you actually get
to do something complicated
you run back right up against the wall
of i need to know how mapred
mapreduce works so i think it's good
that these things are coming out but the
the thing it abstracts is still very
important to know
and i'm not sure we could get away from
that now i mean maybe in time
okay cool so practice scholarly
practical scalding usage so
they use the the pimp my library pattern
uh and we just took that one step
further and
did it again um this co-generated
boilerplate
um so we actually just wrote a scala
program
that like parses over xml definitions of
tables and spits out
a very clean interface for accessing
those tables
and i'll show you an example of that in
a bit so this is super important if
we did this uh everyone was just like
clamoring for it because everyone had
this same problem
of like i have to look at this table and
i don't know what fields i need
and now we give more consistent names
like based off this xml definition
and everyone's super happy all right um
so cascades cascades are a cascading
feature where
like one cascading flow depends on
another flow
and you could do special things so you
could say if if flow
a was stale then regenerate its data
and then give it to flow b so that
that i'll give you an example of a
little bit later but that's not in
scalding
um that's just in cascading but it's i
submitted a pull request and they
accepted it
so it is it is now going to be in the
next version so that's very cool
um traps so often you're producing a lot
of data
in hdfs that is just garbage so
a data warehouse team has to put it
there there's also like click stream
data
people put crazy stuff in fields they're
not supposed to and it all ends up
in your data warehouse so what a trap
does
is say hey i was expecting this to be an
integer and it blew up
just throw it in some separate area and
i could go back and look at it later
so these these are critical for like
making these things work and debugging
because debugging a mapreduce job is
very difficult um as you will see
i'll get into a little bit later also um
and then another important thing is
testing scalding actually has
like an in-memory test framework so you
could say like
given these inputs like you actually
define the tuples that are your input
and then you define the tuples at your
output it will run through your entire
job
and then just validate if it worked so
this is extremely important
because once it's on the cluster like
anything could happen and it's very
difficult to tell if you had a rounding
error
when you're adding like millions of
numbers together
so it's super important to do things on
a known data set
beforehand to make sure you're getting
the actual results you want
okay cool all right so i'll walk you
through some of the code
we wrote over here and i had a large
hand in it
so this pipe boilerplate class
okay so let me just start over you saw
beginning
that extended job before so now we have
an
ebay job which i broke naming convention
for branding purposes here
um and then that extends that job
and then i you know mixed in this pipe
boiler plate so
you'll see an example of pipe boiler
plate later but that's basically that
code generation to get rid of all the
like having to know where every field is
on hdfs all right and then
over here here's where we like extend
the e the rich pipe so the way
uh scalding is implemented is it has
this thing called rich pipe
so every time it sees a pipe it turns it
into a red type and that gives you all
those kind of cool functions like
flat map map whatever else
so what we did was say hey well i'll
just take that a step further
and there's a lot of like common things
people at ebay do over and over again
and they're often annoying so
unfortunately some of the more annoying
things are obscure
so like not everybody knows them and
then you have to go digging for it
so what you do is basically you define a
trait
that imports the various dsl classes
and then you just define a pipe and do
due to the magic of mix-ins
um it ignores this when it like mixes it
in
uh which is really cool and then you
could define all the kind of really
complex functions you want
so whatever mind-blowing code you have
that like you think people just can't
handle
you just wrap it in this abstraction and
then you could call a really complex
function
exactly like we called flat map and this
is
extremely useful so and one example was
uh we wanted to compute quantiles over
like a given category and the items that
sold in it for what price
so we just extended uh the rich pipe
and included a function like compute
quantiles in category
so if anyone wants it now they could
just use it automatically
which is really cool
okay so it reads it ends up writing code
like this
which some might argue is too readable
for scala given the uh
you know that martin nardiski tells you
to use single letter variable names
and things like that so um you end up
with code that basically says hey i want
to get the transactions pipe
and give me some default path logic and
we've defined all that too
for you uh and then this is where the
magic kind of happens so
every field name is in this pipe at this
point
and then i say hey just give me the
fields i need
and you just toss out the name and to
find the name you could just look
through the code
um and this actual like a concrete class
that was also code generated
that has the name like checkout
transactions
so now i have exactly the fields i need
and then i i use this
in a single job this is not shared code
but i did it to kind of make
the the high level flow very readable so
over here you say like um so to give you
some more context
this is actually a user preferences job
so it says like
does this user actually like brand coach
and then give them an affinity towards
that towards that piece of structured
data
so in order to kind of encapsulate that
entire
process you just say like it does a few
things it counts how many times a user
interacted with that piece of structured
data
and then it does a score calculation and
then it does a confidence calculation
so if anyone came up to this code they
could easily just like click into each
bit
and then find the actual you know
calculation that
that i did to be fair there's a couple
of
lines that i left out but uh it's it's
generally very simple
and your code could end up looking like
this so
remember back when you saw that that
like pink code where it was just
like this is why i say it combines the
best of pig and
cascading because the pig code did look
somewhat similar in terms of the use of
like filters and maps and
group buys but it it's not in scala so
inside all these functions whenever i
bring a piece of
data into memory i could use all the
abstractions scala has to offer
and those are even more plentiful than
java which
kind of brings me back to that madness
point so don't go too crazy
okay cool uh here's some other
interesting things we've done
so collaborative filtering is like
typically very difficult to run
on a large data set so there are
libraries like mahoot but they have an
extremely
large learning curve it's like the
examples will run out of the box but
then as soon as you're like okay i'm
going to plug my data into it
you start getting exceptions and you
have to go to the user group
figure out what's wrong i hope this is
going to get better in the future
but it's not as user friendly so i've
noticed a lot of cool things happening
in scalding around this space
so one thing is like edwin chen one of
the guys
worked at twitter just put out a blog
that used uh did a very simple
um item titan similarity algorithm and
it's extremely extensible you basically
just
override the input pipe so you say give
me this input
and then you could do some output
munging too and it just works
so like the barrier to entry to running
collaborative filtering algorithms which
are typically difficult has just like
dropped down to almost nothing
if you have a hadoop cluster uh so this
is this is extremely powerful
and a lot of the abstractions that the
scalding guys are building in
uh go with the same principle so there's
another library called algebra
and it has all sorts of cool things like
one is a a monoi that just gets
average standard deviation and count and
it does this
you know cross mapreduce but it doesn't
need to bring all the data into memory
at once
so they're they're implementing a lot of
algorithms like that that are smart
enough to work on streams of data
instead of viewing the entire data set
in memory at once
uh and that's what using scalding is
really good for
because so you're kind of leveraging
those abstractions to do more and more
complicated things
but you're doing it in a simple way
what else so so to be fair
these methods of collaborative filtering
are a little less precise
than some of like the other
state-of-the-art methods but i think the
point is
that like if you could get that up and
running you could make something better
for your customer
tomorrow rather than like six months
from now
which is super cool and if you're super
interested in machine learning
uh one of my colleagues chris sivers is
giving a talk at scala
at the scala conference uh about this
and
uh i could i'll post a comment on the
board
but definitely check it out
okay so here's another cool piece of
tech
we built using scala and cascading
um this is structured data importance so
it's kind of like a user has affinity to
a certain brand
but in aggregate what what do people
generally
like decide to shop you know based
around what aspects do people decide to
shop
so if you go to the store do you first
look for the brand or do you look for
the color of the thing you want
uh or do you look for the size so like
all of these are various
aspects and this kind of represents the
supply we have
on the site so so this this job is kind
of like
important for two reasons like if bag
depth was really important
but had no supply maybe we need to tell
people to start like
listing it more and also if you
if you notice the ebay search experience
you'll see a left navigation
and there are certain aspects you could
actually click on and then
when you click on them it filters the
results so above the fold you only have
opportunity to show like
x number of things so you have to like
figure out
what they are so remember that crazy
dag i showed you from before that that's
this job
um and the reason that dag is so crazy
is it's a linear model
um that's computed completely on hadoop
uh the the coefficients of this model
are not learned on hadoop
but they very well could be and
and then they just plug it in and then
it'll compute your model for you
so you could do you could do things like
that pretty simply without like
resorting to
frameworks or anything like that which i
think is
pretty good one other interesting thing
that this job used is structured data
extraction
so we have these like other machine
learned models
that are that are used within hadoop
context
so say you're like streaming over a
bunch of search queries
and you want to know did that person
mention a brand or not
so you could build a completely offline
model that is like
partitioned in some way and then you use
hadoop
to stream over this massive data set
so you load that machine learn model
into memory and then you just stream all
your data through it
and output more and more tuples and this
is like
when you have 1500 like machines doing
this for you
uh it gets done a lot quicker than you
could ever imagine
like doing it on your own so you could
scale simple models
across huge amounts of data by using uh
hadoop and mapreduce which brings me
back
to the earliest point of that trait you
saw till do io once
that was because of this so i had seen
it it had been used once inside the
context of a mapper
i realized it definitely could cause
problems so you only want to do that i o
once
so that's kind of why that earlier trait
was created as well
some other cool things you should do
like practical concerns
especially with this job uh was like
this graph was built out of a sql light
database
so often your mapreduce jobs will like
turn over immense events big data
and then at the end of it you end up
with something that's like very small
and they're like i want to ask some more
questions about what i outputted so you
just chuck it in a sqlite database
and then you can figure everything out
from there
okay cool uh here's here's a
particularly cool piece of scholar code
that i recently wrote um we did some
markov chains
to investigate the buying patterns and
it's about 50 total lines of scalding
code
but here's the kind of meat of it and
this this
this is why you can't do these kind of
things in pig
right um so this is all in the context
of a reducer
but i've i've used like all the cool
stuff scala has to offer
to basically compute this in a few lines
of code
and these lines of code here are like
almost identical
to what i wrote to test it in a single
threaded context
and then i just basically copied and
pasted it into a reducer
and then ran it on the cluster and the
first shot it came out with the data i
wanted
um a cool thing here is how it like
uh so a markov chain is just like
given your current state what's the
probability you will advance to the next
state um
so you could imagine this state as you
bought something and you're going to
advance to the next day to buying
something else
so what you're looking at here are like
the purchases
that somebody made and then we're
figuring out the probability that
they're going to move on to the next
state
which is like you're going to buy the
next you know what next
product right so this is pretty useful
and then i just use this cool trick to
like get the first time probability
here um so
yeah so you're not looking at a
mapreduce code you know
raw this isn't like scalding code this
is just scala
that's being used um does that make
sense to everybody any questions
okay cool all right
uh here's a very interesting job again
uh we had to mine search queries so
there's billions of search queries
associated with a given user on ebay
a lot of a lot of the queries they make
are done before they're logged in so
they're not fully associated
with the user but if you want to know
what other top queries for a user
like various use cases could be like
it's like a safe search type of thing
like here you search for these things a
lot
um maybe you want to follow it um
something along those lines
so so this job here really kind of took
all the lessons we learned about hadoop
and implemented them
so these 20 billion user queries are not
in a single place they're
mixed in with click stream data so to
actually get to them
you have to parse over tons and tons of
click stream data
so it doesn't make sense to every time
you want to do that like
look through the fact that you clicked
on an item click the back button
did it did something else um this is
useless
and there's like petabytes of it so what
you do is you just
you go over it once dump it to a known
location
for a given day and what uh what
cascading allows you to do is basically
say hey if this day is computed already
just like go on with your life uh don't
recompute it
uh so that's the that's the perfect
example of like
a great abstraction cascading gives you
um so then okay so now we have all these
queries that are
on the disk and they're isolated uh what
do we have to do
so one typical thing is like deduping
them
so like uh you could run some
tokenization on them
this is actually what we did ransom
tokenization and then we use like this
unique function in cascading which
basically
sends every query to a bunch of mappers
and it keeps a few in memory and says
if i saw it already like get rid of it
um
and then it pushes everything to a
reducer which has the effect
of deduping naturally also uh
so that is pretty cool so now you've
deduped a lot of the useless queries
but you've retained the ones that are
the newest
and the ones that are the oldest out of
all of those
so now you can rank so you could say
like if someone has searched for
something
um a year ago and then they did it six
months ago and then they're still doing
it today
that's probably pretty important to them
so you could write a ranking function
around that
it's very easy to get like mins and
maxes of things
in a in a map-reduced kind of context so
that worked out really well
um another thing is like some kind of
like
fuzzy matching right like given the user
did x number of things you rank the top
bunch of them
and maybe you say like well these two
things are really the same
but since you've like reduced your data
set down so much
you can now actually like run a more
comprehensive algorithm
to say like these two pieces of text are
exactly the same
so so a lot of these jobs like you'll
see this a lot in mapreduce is you start
out with a lot of data
you you whittle it down you whittle it
down you do the easy things to get what
you want
and then you can finally get it into a
compact enough representation
where you can do something like really
cool to it
um which is uh
you know pretty typical uh so this
brings me back to a point i'm going over
20 billion user queries if some of them
are buggy
how the heck am i going to be able to
tell so i can't just like attach a
debugger
to every jvm that's running in our
hadoop cluster
that wouldn't work so what you can do is
count things so
hadoop gives you this abstraction called
counters and it lets you
just as you see something you increment
increment
so what we did was we put
counters in for bad situations so
anytime you saw a bad situation you
gotta count
and then when the job ended cascading
gives you
a list of all the counters that ran and
all the flows
and then it just you could run
validators over it so this is a good use
for like scholarly validation
which is pretty cool you could just run
validators over all the flows
that were ever ever done okay so
you have a bunch of jobs you have a
bunch of scholar code running these jobs
and now i like someone asked me to i
want this updated daily
okay so so what do i do here um
so this is pretty simple this is how we
do it uh because everything is scala
and cascading we just basically use
jenkins to compile it and then we say
hey jenkins
go and and send that compiled code over
to the hadoop proxy
and because like i mentioned it it
handles all this uh
dependency of various
flows and jobs within this hadoop
context it's it's easy just to package
up a single jar and send it over
and you don't need a complex scheduling
framework like azkaban necessarily
depends how crazy you go you can just
make a simple jenkins job that says hey
trigger this bash script
that runs this job and then you wait on
the status
and then when the status is complete you
just say hey jenkins
okay go back there tell it to download
the file so
jenkins compiled it sent it over
it then said execute it okay and then it
said oh
all right it's done okay download the
file and then
sync it over to these batch database
load machines so these are just vms that
we have
and once they're there then jenkins also
kicks off another process that says like
okay get this data into the database and
that's where our data goes into
cassandra
so those user profile uh these user
preferences i talked about before which
is like
like brand x that goes in cassandra and
various other stuff like that aspect
important stuff goes in my sequel
same thing with those user queries and
some legacy stuff goes into [ __ ]
as well all right so
i think that about wraps it up um
does anyone have any questions
you sir
yeah what do you mean about the catalog
sorry
oh okay so we
okay the question was about h catalog
and had we looked at it
um so to be honest that kind of
decisions out of my hands
uh the hadoop group is a bunch of people
and they have things that support like
teradata and other kind of big
like data warehouse stores so they have
their own system and i don't exactly
know what it is
but it publishes similar metadata which
we used for code generation so i could
imagine you could do the same thing
with another suite of software
all right free light bulbs for questions
okay
oh yes you're very observant sir okay so
uh the scalding the
the api we're using currently is not
type safe
so the only type of safety you get is
actually like once you're
executing code so like back here
now i get type safety but that that x
variable
where i'm getting stuff out of there's
no type safety on that
um there is a type safe api that's in
development
and it basically lets you pass classes
around so it will always validate that
like
okay you gave this segment of code a
like
atom class and you're getting back a foo
class
and then it wires type safety throughout
the whole process
so i don't have an example but like you
can imagine there being types
on every one of these things like count
user inaction return some type
uh and that's what they're doing with
the typed api yeah
you sir um
so we use all sorts of stuff there's
like sequence files
um and there's tsv's so
a lot of this data is created by this
data warehouse team and we're kind of
stuck with what they give us
but when we sample it we've done a
combination like
occasionally we use sequence files and a
serialization format
but often we'll just use tsv because i
could go to it and look at it
which is actually quite valuable so
we tend to gravitate towards like
readable
readable readable text
cool
sorry multi-core oh so
okay so we haven't done any kind of
uh multi-core processing within the
mapreduce flows themselves
but uh you certainly can so uh
all these frameworks let you actually
get pretty close to the metal of
mapreduce
and there are methods in there where you
could override and it would let you
like do multi-core processing so
one example is like if you just
aggregated a bunch of stuff and you know
it fits in memory
maybe it's faster to do multi-core
processing on it
we haven't run into a situation where we
necessarily needed to do that
one of the problems with doing that is
you kind of starve everyone out
so like if i go nuts on my like one
reducer
and i'm sharing that node with a bunch
of other people which
is very common at ebay we have like many
clients of the hadoop cluster
you basically like consume all the
resources
of that reducer hadoop doesn't have very
good boundaries between like
different tenants so if one tenant takes
out the system
it like kills it for everyone else so
that's kind of why i haven't
me personally haven't done that but
there's definitely you could do it
sorry could you say that louder
queuing system yeah so there is a
queuing system uh
that like you could kind of give people
certain priorities
over other people but you don't have any
control of where the task ultimately
gets run
so the task is going to be scheduled out
by the map reduced framework
it's going to land on some worker and if
you starve out that worker and start
failing everyone else's jobs
there's nothing they can do about it
uh so that's a good question uh no we're
using python
um because uh we like python as well
and it was very easy to do we were
familiar with it
but you certainly could use scalding i
think this kind of like
general framework just supports anything
i do have one job that creates bloom
filters that
uses java i certainly could have done
that in scala
i just i just didn't
yes
okay yeah so the question was uh how
does it play with different versions of
hadoop
um i believe so i've run scalding code
on like 0.22 if i recall we're
we're on a newer version of that so
it does work i was able to get it to
work on like an older version of
mapreduce and i know there's
there's two specific mapreduce apis and
it does support both of them there's
like the old style if you actually look
through the mapreduce code you'll see
like an if statement
like use new api use old one so you can
get it to run with the old api
code um i'm not sure exactly what the
problem
you ran into was it's possible they
didn't cover all the cases
but um generally it's
it's kind of friendly i i found um so
what's the stuff we do here
yeah uh
yeah sorry okay
yeah yeah yeah so yeah it's definitely
interesting also cascading is built
against specific versions
of uh uh hadoop also but
they i think in general they try to be
friendly to the older versions because
like it's a place like ebay gets stuck
on an old version
and you actually like need to take the
cluster down to upgrade it
so it becomes very difficult to you know
upgrade like
seamlessly like you can't just you have
to actually take the thing down
cool uh any other questions
yeah so uh hadoop supports like
g-zipping i believe by default and it
also has a
it has a splittable compressed format
like
the name is escaping me um but
definitely the data we
use is zipped up um but the thing is
when you choose to use compression on
hadoop you have to keep in mind
splitability
so when you're trying to like farm tests
out to mappers
if you can't split at arbitrary points
of a file
then you can't actually like get it to a
mapper without truncating
like something useful uh so yeah we do
use
i believe we don't use this the
splittable one but i'd have to double
check
cool yes
yeah so so we've originally started
using
so i had learned scala in conjunction
with cascading
uh to be fair so we originally just had
scala
calling cascading directly so we didn't
write anything in java
and that's kind of when i started
picking up scala so
you know i i'd say um
i think like my early scholar to be
honest looked a lot like java
so like i look back at things i did
before and i see myself like
incrementing data into mutable lists and
i'm like what the heck was i thinking
but um that's kind of the evolution i
took over it
and then when when i started getting
better and better at scala
i found cascading as scalding more and
more appealing because it
kind of melded with the functional
constructs that i was learning
so cool
yeah so uh the guy i mentioned who's
giving the talk
uh at skaldes he's a big proponent of it
and so you could imagine like all of our
data warehouse tables are stored
in like this type of serialization and
that would uh
make things a lot easier in certain
cases so
people do use it and they like it i
think um
we just haven't jumped into it um
because we haven't had a
like a real strong pressing need to do
it but it's definitely
something to consider if you're starting
fresh and like writing tables into
hadoop that many people are going to be
using
like avro is a good it's a good choice
cool all right anyone else
you know
all right cool well uh thank you all for
coming
um i hope this was informative if you
want to follow up anything new about
ebay like go to our website
um we are hiring of course and we love
scala
here uh we are also trying to get scala
into more visible places in ebay
so for instance all the recommendation
services currently run on java
and we're like experimenting right like
right now people are pushing code
that is going to get scala like serving
recommendations
so we're experimenting it with in more
places than just to do
which is really cool so thank you
and uh good night